[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
big changes in the tiny hot house and it
is tiny of cable news this evening
cnn's top-rated anchor chris cuomo has
been pulled off the air likely for good
you'll probably never see him on camera
again
for us here at fox it feels like the end
of something like most americans we
never actually watched the chris cuomo
show assuming that was its name but over
the years we saw his clips and they
transfixed us
very often as a public service but also
because honestly we could not help
ourselves we brought them to you
how we wondered did a man who could
barely speak english wind up with a
paying job on television was it some
kind of weird affirmative action program
for the illiterate
we never figured it out but it was
remarkable to see it
sentence after badly mangled sentence a
boolea base of incomprehensible grammar
you couldn't understand any of it
it was a kind of performance art a
communicator wholly unable to
communicate
and then there was the weightlifting
there's nothing wrong with lifting
weights or keeping in shape obviously
but there was always something very
wrong with the videos that chris cuomo
had shot of himself and then put on the
internet imagine wanting other people to
see this
sorry i've been really busy but i am
working out a minute to be honest you
don't get to look like that
let's get a little pre-show pump what
does that say
uh cuomo prime time hashtag let's get
after it 100 pounds you know just kind
of just work it out a little bit light
stuff
[Music]
news time
we're also uh using that fred flinstone
dumbbell
this is multitasking for a real man
oh his poor staff so yes we did make fun
of chris cuomo quite a bit on this show
in fact pretty relentlessly for the past
five years chris cuomo was a buffoon
he was also in the way that buffoons
tend to be incredibly self-righteous and
false
here he is for example pretending to
emerge from self-imposed quarantine in
his basement after recovering from covid
we had a huge day today in casa cuomo
take a look at this
all right here it is the official
re-entry from the basement
cleared by cdc a little sweaty just
worked out happens
this is what i've been dreaming of
literally for weeks this
is the dream just to be back up here
doing normal things
ah his poor family he pulled them into
it
we learned later the whole thing was
fake chris cuomo hadn't quarantined in
fact he'd been out and about wandering
around long island without a mask
yelling at anyone who questioned him
now no one else at the time in the media
seemed bothered at all by this but it
struck us as a big deal it was too phony
but his bosses didn't care before you
knew it chris cohen was back on
television barking at you for yes
not wearing a mask
put on the damn mask if you're in
california if you're in riverside wear
the mask if you want to avoid situations
like this where you live wear the mask
if we care about doing the right things
i wear a mask for you as much as i wear
it for me i had the disease you need to
wear a damn mask right and you have to
take care of other people in your
community and it's got to be about us
because the help's not going to come
from above
said the guy who screamed at someone
else for pointing out that he was not
wearing a mask
now at the time that seemed pretty
unforgivable to us in fact watching the
tape it still does seem unforgivable but
once again chris cuomo's bosses weren't
bothered at all it's cnn there is no
penalty for falseness
the only thing you can't do at cena and
the thing that they will never tolerate
is displeasing the people in charge that
means not simply jeff zucker who runs
the company but the billionaires who run
our country if you cross them you're
done
so this morning when we saw the atlantic
magazine we knew it was curtains for
chris cuomo the atlantic is owned by
steve jobs widow it functions as a kind
of modern social register a place for
the ruling class to talk to itself and
the atlantic decided that it was deeply
displeased chris cuomo had dared to help
his brother the former governor of new
york when he was accused of sexual
harassment chris cuomo must go the
atlantic declared and then we knew he
would we knew it was over in the world
that jeff zucker lives in the atlantic
makes the rules cuomo was done
and that's when for the first time ever
and very unexpectedly we started to feel
sorry for chris cuomo
helping his brother is not the worst
thing chris cuomo ever did in fact it
may have been the best thing he ever did
not because andrew cuomo was a good
person he certainly wasn't a good person
andrew cuomo was loathsome but andrew
cuomo was chris cuomo's brother
and that's what you do with brothers
even the loathsome ones you help them
when they need it
period it's called loyalty
at cnn as at the rest of the media this
is an alien concept
is there a single person at cnn or any
other left-wing network who would risk
his job to help his own brother
no
above all these people are careerists
ruthless careerists they would betray
anyone to get ahead if jeff zucker told
this guy to denounce his own wife on
television do you think he'd hesitate
before doing it of course he wouldn't
not for a second
so when we tell you that the media are
corrupt we don't just mean they're
corrupt politically it is much deeper
than that
they don't acknowledge the most
important rules in life
your first obligation is to your family
your first obligation is not to the
state it's not to a political party it's
not to jeff zucker or some creepy
billionaires at the atlantic magazine
it's not even to your own career your
most basic obligation is to the people
you are related to
when they need your help no matter who
they are even if they're the governor of
a state even if they're horrible people
you help them anyway because it's your
family
chris cuomo may be an idiot and he is
but he understands that
what a thing to be fired for hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else